- 12 years ago today,
I asked somebody on my
team to run to BestBuy,
pick up a little Canon camera, set it up,
I picked three bottles of wine,
I put them on a table, I filmed it,
first time I ever filmed anything
with the purpose of anybody seeing it.
Hello everyone, and welcome
to the first episode
of Wine Library TV.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
director of operations
here at Wine Library and winelibrary.com.
And it started the process
of where we are here today,
12 years later.
(intense music)
When I hear people lacking patience
or wanting it so fast, or not
understanding the marathon,
I've basically been producing
content for the internet
for the last 12 years
and I really wish so many
of you could understand
how quick that's gone and
how much longer I have to go
but most of all, realize how much
didn't happen in those
first several years.
(intense music)
How much I needed to persevere
and build an audience,
how much engaging and
applying people along the way
and building relationships and
hugging and kissing babies,
and grinding, and
believing and most of all
what's so interesting
is I sit here right now
outside this airport
knowing that 65% of you
didn't know who I was 24
months ago, 15 months ago.
At my current place of attention
is a current phenomenon,
it's a 15-16 month phenomenon
that things kind of took
a little bit of a hockey stick moment
which means 10 and a half years.
10 and a half years of
grinding and putting out stuff
and wanting to share my
thoughts on wine, on business,
on entrepreneurship, day in and day out.
Day in and day out, wow,
I worked all the time,
building businesses while this wasn't even
my full time thing.
I have so much empathy that you want it,
I have so much empathy and
want for you to get yours,
but Jesus, this doesn't happen overnight.
It just doesn't.
(intense music)